Khloe Kardashian gives birth to her
first child the reality star and her NBA
pro boyfriend Tristan Thompson are
officially parents et learned that Koko
was pregnant in September just days
after it was revealed that her younger
sister Kylie Jenner was expecting a baby
with Travis Scott a source told ET at
the time quote it's no secret that Khloe
was eager to become a mother this is
something she has wanted for a long time
and finally the timing is right
Kardashian and the Cleveland Cavaliers
player were first romantically linked in
August 2016 and were spotted on vacation
together in Mexico the following month
in October her momager Kris Jenner told
ET that her daughter was in a great
place
we love Tristan so much and she's so
happy and she's been through so much to
have and be in such a great place in her
personal life is amazing yeah she's
really happy but the days leading up to
Khloe's delivery have been a turbulent
time for the couple as reports surfaced
that Tristan allegedly cheated on Khloe
with multiple women a source previously
told ET that Khloe quote is completely
devastated by the allegations adding
Tristan is a man Khloe built a life with
and saw as her forever
[Music]
[Applause]